they the International Federation of
photographic industries reported that
one-third of all compact discs sold last
year were pirated amounting to a loss of
4.6 billion dollars to the recording
industry in hot property author Pat
Choate looks at the history of piracy
since the 1800s the program is just over
an hour okay good evening folks we are
we're ready to begin welcome to politics
and prose bookstore I'm like Jarrett on
oh and I for the staff and the owners
here at the store I thank you for coming
in and joining us this evening we
welcome Patt Choate tonight he's a he's
a historian a political economist a
think-tank strategist in a policy
analyst this is his fourth time speaking
at the store this time around he's here
for his latest book hot property the
stealing of ideas and age of
globalization he will speak for about 20
minutes to a half hour and then we'll
have time for questions which we will
feel from our audience microphone if you
could get to that it would be convenient
and to keep the talk audible how
property addresses addresses
intellectual property rights from their
inclusion in the US Constitution to the
current attack they're under by theft
and piracy this is negatively of
impacting the US economy risking health
and safety and thinning creativity
innovation and authenticity ultimately
there is a dire role to be played by the
US government in taking more competitive
measures to protect our interests again
thanks for coming in this evening patch
Mike thank you very much and thank you
for coming it's a pleasure to be back at
politics it froze and like many of you
have seen the store grow from across the
street here and bigger and bigger and
that is a pleasurable thing I'm going to
start off with just paying a few
personal observations writing books for
me is is is in many ways a painful
pleasure i call it eventually the work
is done the less last corrected galley
is sent back to the publisher and then
there's a period of several months
between the time that the galley is in
and it's being printed and you get the
first copy of the book and there's
almost a postpartum depression as a
writer of you know that part of your
life is over as you think about what
your next book will be but it's also a
period of time that gives the author an
opportunity to reflect don't just want
the book is about you know what what did
I just spend three or four years on
what's it about and I've done that with
this book and hopefully I and I think
this book is a strong and well
documented well documented advocacy for
strong intellectual property laws not
only in the United States in the world
these protections are the very
foundation of our economy the principle
means that we have to stimulate
innovation and ideas in our country the
new ideas and the innovations that flow
from these protections have profoundly
shaped the lines of the American people
in this country for almost 200 years
they've enabled the United States to
achieve an extraordinary standard of
living maintain our national security
and assist people everywhere enjoy a
better life now despite that importance
and it is important as I think you had
described what we also find is I think
at first one is most people think of
intellectual property as a truly dull
topic
though but important dbi that standard
that affects so many public policy
issues it certainly in practice its
technical it involves compact complex
legal concepts it is deeply mired in
obscure politics it is dominated by
people and bureaucratic organizations
known primarily to the lawyers
bureaucrats and technicians or put
another way very few children in America
grow up wanting to be a corporate
intellectual property counsel this is
not high on their list the question for
a writer the question for me in doing
this is how do you take an important
topic where there is maybe a bit of
prejudice against it as being
interesting and how do you make it an
interesting subject for the reader how
do you give access to the reader well
the answer of course is stories you tell
stories of artists and inventors and
musicians and other creative people it's
their experiences that are fascinating
and sometimes odd sometimes as you will
find in the book some of these stories
are almost unbelievable for example
Thomas Edison hired a pseudo scientist
to publicly electrocute large dogs and
horses to scare the public away from
george westinghouse alternating current
electric system you wound up with a
situation in New York State where Edison
was financing efforts to electrocute
criminals as a means of discrediting
Westinghouse and you wound with George
Westinghouse financing the legal appeals
for everyone on death row that's odd the
Cunard shipping company put a fourth
funnel on the Titanic a fake funnel on
the Titanic to make the public think the
ship was as fast and as sophisticated as
its German rivals elife Whitney got a
contract to produce 10,000 muskets
though he had no expiry
none in making arms he had no factory he
had no machinery he had no workers and
he was bankrupt he promised delivery
within two years but ten years to do his
contract a precedent for some other
defense contracts he falsified his
progress reports tricking President
Adams and Jefferson into thinking he was
producing interchangeable parts when he
was not though he eventually did despite
all of that you wound up with Eli
Whitney inventing interchangeable parts
the assembly line of manufacturing and
he totally changed manufacturing in the
history in here and in the history of
the world Alexander Graham Bell made one
great invention in his life and it was
the telephone it is considered the most
perfect patent ever written it is the
most profitable patent ever ridden yet
bells application reach the Patent
Office only two hours before an
application from elisha gray a prominent
chicago inventor who sued Bell
repeatedly until gray died one associate
of Elisha gray said of him that of all
the people who did not invent the
telephone first gray was the closest
it took the patent office only three
weeks to review and approve belts patent
the bell patent was challenged six and
six hundred lawsuits five of which went
to the Supreme Court Bell one every suit
Alexander grams bailed story part let me
clear my throat is awesome one of
America's great love stories and I tell
this in this book bounce sponsor the
Ballon came to the United States from
Scotland into Canada his two brothers
had died of tuberculosis and he had to
leave edinboro he thought to survive he
came from a very distinguished family of
educators bells great sponsor in the
United States was a man now forgotten
named Gardner Hubbard hubbard had hired
Bell to come to Boston to run the school
for the deaf and to teach his death
teenage daughter and eventually the 19
year old maple Hubbard and 27 year old
Alexander Graham Bell fell in love and
they married on their wedding night Bell
as his gift to his bride gave her every
share of stock in the bell telephone
company all of his shares now what makes
that extraordinary is her father was the
manager a brand the Bell captain he was
very clever and a very astute
businessman belt cared nothing for the
business he'd want to teach deaf
children but what happened is when
Gardner Hubbard died the stock went to
Mabel Hubbard Mabel Hubbert was the
largest single stockholder in the bell
telephone company and she could never
use it because never used the phone
because she was deaf an interesting you
know irony of history Hubbard invented
franchising
in America the first Bell company was
set up on a model that McDonald's would
later use in fast food and it worked
just fabulously the greatest monument to
Hubbard that we see nationally is
Hubbard founded the national geographic
society and it was Alexander Graham Bell
after Hubbard died who took over the
responsibilities and at that point he
really wanted someone to run the
National Geographic and he had a friend
who was a diplomat who had two 21 year
old sons he invited the 21 year old sons
to join them in Canada for six weeks in
the summer one of the sons wanted to run
the the National Geographic he also
wanted to marry bells daughter and that
was the beginning of the National
Geographic now in writing the book I
divided into three parts the first
section explains the history of the
patent system its value to the nation
and its abused by pirates and
counterfeiters the second section
explains how germany used innovation and
patents to become in the late nineteenth
and early century to become a great
world power it describes how Japan did
the same thing in the middle 20th
century and it analyzes how China is
doing the same thing today now let me
just start with some basics own the
intellectual property system this is
I'll try not to make this dull because I
want to go back to a bunch of stories
that I that I want to share with you
first of all ideas are the foundation in
which patents copyrights trademarks and
trade secrets are created through the
purest product of the mind through the
greatest most stable source of the
wealth of nations the knowledge that
flows and ideas is the dominant if not
the only competitive source of advantage
they're intangible their femoral yet
they're the wellspring of creativity
ideas cannot be owned
but producing the creations that flow
from them can be property with all the
rights bestowed on property owners at
least for a set period of time
intellectual property law is about
classifying the form an idea takes the
right to exclude others from its use the
enforcement of that right the penalties
for any infringement of that right the
assignment of responsibility for
imposing the punishment and equally
important to all of that the attendant
obligation of the intellectual property
owner to the larger society to share
knowledge now with potential so vast
this is an area of enormous amounts of
pirating and counterfeiting the way that
I view and I think the way the founding
fathers viewed intellectual property is
that it is a social contract between
society and creative people it's a
golden covenant it is a golden covenant
by which the public grants someone the
right to exclude others from using their
creation for a specified period of time
in exchange for the creative person
disclosing the details of their creation
and ultimately surrendering that
creation to enter the public domain
where everyone can use and build on the
knowledge it is knowledge for exclusive
use ultimately that is the Golden
Covenant now the hope of the Golden
Covenant is Bank making that grant is
the general state of knowledge will be
advanced that has worked wonderfully
well in the United States in the United
States the protections of that right
flows directly from the US constitution
article 1 section 8 grants Congress the
power quote to promote the progress of
science and the useful arts by securing
for limited times and authors and
inventors the exclusive right to their
respective writings and discoveries this
idea was so firmly held by the founding
fathers
that its constitutional convention there
was no debate and this provision was
passed on a unanimous vote moreover this
is the only place in the body of the
Constitution where the term right is
explicitly mentioned the constitutional
amendments that became known as the bill
of rights were not ratified until almost
the end of the third year of George
Washington's first presidential turn and
almost 19 months after the passage of
the first patent and copyright acts in
1790 this 27 word clause is the legal
basis for every patent and every
copyright ever issued in the United
States over time four types of basic
intellectual property protections have
been created patents copyrights
trademarks and trade law and in the book
I trace out the history of each one and
it's a raucous history let me assure you
trademarks were first developed in the
1870s and the great promoters of
trademarks were the producers of bourbon
and literally what was happening is the
people were producing bourbon too
unsophisticated drinkers it tasted the
like and so they differentiated by the
shape of the bottles and the labels etc
other parts of our intellectual property
system have almost the same interesting
background now all of that said let's
get the stories I begin the first
chapter with the inauguration of George
Washington and it's a fitting beginning
April thirtieth 1789 downtown new york
city city hall suddenly became the
capital of the United States noon and
what was interesting is when George
Washington appeared George Washington is
presented as a very dour May
in our history chopping a cherry tree
you know wooden teeth etc church
Washington was in many ways anything but
that he was a fascinating man he was a
rich planner he was a surveyor he was a
soldier he had his suits made in london
by custom tailors of silk and velvet
George Washington was the ultimate party
gore George Washington was known at
Mount Vernon forgiving dances where he
would dance all through the night one of
the things that he did all through the
Revolutionary War he imposed a fee on
all of his officers so they could do
three social events throughout the year
to build a spree but given all of that
an extraordinary thing happened when he
was inaugurated in 1789 he showed up in
a brown suit of homespun broadcloth a
gift from the hartford woolen
manufactory a small milk in Connecticut
every item that he wore his shoes his
belt the buttons on his jacket his suit
had been made in the United States he
came there and did that to make a
personal gesture to for the need for
America to create a strong domestic
manufacturing base as a general who led
the fighting during the revolution
Washington knew that the war had almost
been lost several times because of the
lack of materials during the war America
benicar lean it had won its hard-won
freedom just barely at Bunker Hill the
soldiers only had nine rounds of
ammunition the American soldiers
finished the battle of bunker hill using
their muskets as clubs on the British in
Valley Forge and the winner of Valley
Forge one of the famous letters of
Washington to the Congress is that
literally he had two thousand five
hundred troops out
Commission because they lacked shoes
shirts or blankets now an indication of
the dependence and the situation that
the founding fathers faced and why they
became so intent on creating a
manufacturing base and and having
intellectual property rights to
stimulate it is found in Benjamin
Franklin's less to purchases and France
when he went there to try to buy the
tools of war what he bought was 80,000
shirts 80,000 blankets a hundred tons of
gunpowder eight ships of the line
muskets and a hundred artillery pieces
then Franklin had to arrange for the
whole thing to be passed a British naval
blockade that involved half the British
Navy a four thousand mile three-month
journey to the Caribbean where the goods
then had to be transshipped are
transparent to smugglers who then
brought it into the colonies on a 1,400
mile trip that took another six weeks
not surprisingly Washington's first
priority was to develop American
industries in his first State of the
Union message he called for a patent and
copyright act and among the first
legislation the first Congress passed
was the patent and copyright act in
April and May of 1790 those laws were
passed moreover the issuance of a patent
was made and the highest order of the
state the patent board consisted of the
Secretary of State Thomas Jefferson
Secretary of War Henry Knox an attorney
general Edmund Randolph the three met on
the last saturday of every month if to
the three voted favorably a patent
letter was presented for George
Washington signature once signed by the
President the Secretary of State signed
the letter he affixed the great steel of
the United States and the cost of the
inventor was five dollars and that money
went to the core
work who embossed this there were 57
those patents issued in two years if if
you happen to have one of those patent
applications just for the signatures on
it is an important historical artifacts
but strangely what happened and it was
one of great martyr factor great
mortification for Jefferson the patent
board couldn't meet their duty they were
surprised they figured if they offered a
golden covenant should have people want
to take it they were surprised by the
number of people there was a latent
creativity and so though they issued 57
they wound up with over 200 applications
it overwhelmed them and so what happened
is the Congress made a shift into the
patent laws instead of having a patent
system of very tight controls in 1793
they set up a patent system of very weak
controls they set up a system where
literally all that an inventor had to do
was go to the federal court and register
the patent if there were a conflict that
let the federal courts and lawsuit
sorted out so suddenly you had hundreds
of patent applications come in many for
the same invention and the courts
immediately became clogged with lawsuits
now far Alexander Hamilton and others of
that era that was not an undesirable
outcome Hamilton in his report on
manufacturing laid out a strategy where
the United States would go out and seek
and get even steal the best technologies
in the world and so a system was set up
at that particular point that in effect
with those weak laws made the United
States the great pirate in
counterfeiting haven of the world in the
first 50 years of America's existence we
did not issue a single patent to a
foreigner in the first hundred and one
years of very
distance we did not issue a single
copyright to a foreigner we literally
were a pirate Haven but what we did is
in less than a year we went from an
agricultural former colony to the
greatest industrial power in the world
so I point that out to only say that we
have no moral advantage when we talk
about other countries stealing
technology are engaged in piracy etc
what we need to do is recognize this is
a natural course of this is the natural
course of development now one of the
things I do is I illustrate the
consequences of a loose patent system
but telling the story of eli whitney who
invented the cotton gin mass production
manufacturing this is not the story we
learned in college it is not a mythical
story it is one of the things that you
learn is that Whitney truly had a
co-inventor it was Katherine green the
Witter the widow of general Nathaniel
Greene the Revolutionary War hero during
the war General Greene who was one of
Washington's favorites and an heir to a
Rhode Island fortune had liquidated his
entire fortune including selling his
home to feed armed and closed his troops
and though he did that Congress quibbled
with him about the nature of his
receipts and refused to pay him now the
state of Georgia which Green had
liberated from the British was more
grateful it gave the destitute general
after the war mulberry Grove the state
of a displaced Tory who had left the
state after the war the 44 year old
green who refused to own slaves he was a
Quaker worked himself to death and he
died of a heat stroke leaving his
31-year old widow and five children with
a debt-ridden plantation by borrowing
money she kept the plantation a lie
even as she petitioned Congress for her
hunt for her husband's expenses finally
she got the money to a special act of
Congress through the help of President
George Washington enter Eli Whitney in
1793 he's a graduate of Yale University
he has a teaching job set up in New York
City the job disappears it turns out
that a former graduate of Yale and now
the overseer of mulberry Grove is
seeking a tutor to assist a large
plantation owner in South Carolina
Whitney it's like most college graduates
then and now was deeply in debt he took
the job so the overseer said why don't
you come down from New Haven to New York
and take the ship with mrs. Greene and
myself from here to Savannah wouldn't he
agreed he went down there well it turns
out it was an absolute nightmare and
it's it fits into the story it on the
first leg of the trip from Connecticut
to New York City Whitney ship floundered
it hell's gate six miles from his
destination and most the passengers made
of the shore the passengers then took a
wagon into town when Whitney got to town
he saw an old friend he rushed up shook
his hands before realizing that the man
had an active case of smallpox which at
that time had a fatality rate of thirty
percent Katherine green a very can-do
person and she merits a movie on her own
she's just terrific she took charge she
had Whitney inoculated with a small
amount of small packs spores which he
actually got the disease that reduced
his odds to one in a hundred he survived
and they only had 14 pock marks but he
had to be kept in isolation for two
weeks
and for the two weeks they took the trip
from New York to Savannah and of course
Whitney was seasick the whole time and
as a result of this Katherine green
invited him to come to her plantation
with her family for a few days he went
there and as a gift to her she did
needlepoint he she made a timber that's
a frame to do needlepoint and it was
very neatly done seeing his cleverness
that Katherine green asked him almost as
large can you invent something that
would remove the seed from cotton fiber
cotton fiber was in exotica it's been
around for 3,000 years the Egyptians
used it was used in South America it was
called the vegetable cloth to put it in
context at that point in time only four
percent of cloth used in Britain and
elsewhere was made of cotton it was a
very valuable thing most of it was made
most of class was made out of wool he
took a look at the challenge now this
has been a challenge that existed for
3,000 years he had a flash and
inspiration he said yeah he could do it
in 10 days he not only figured out how
to do it the basic part of it he built
an operating model the model itself
could do the work of 50 men pulling it
out just grind it he had one small
problem it was these pins running
against each other and he knew a great
deal about pins because he had paid his
way through Yale making hat pins for
ladies and it was a question of how do
you get the cotton across and it was
Katherine green that figured that out
she went and took a broom from the
fireplace and said Oh we'll just figure
away that will have a mechanical broom
that'll clear it off and so suddenly you
had the working and I cotton gin
Katherine green put up the money for a
company they split the company 5050 to
do it he went to Washington to get a
patent
the person that he went and saw was
Thomas Jefferson you imagined a 26-year
25 year old guy said oh I've got a great
idea can I speak to the Secretary of
State about it and Thomas Jefferson came
in and it was as the Whitney couldn't
get away from Thomas Jefferson he was
fascinated by the cotton gin at the same
time Katherine green and her plantation
overseer invited neighbors in to see the
chin in this fabulous thing that was
going to improve all of their lives
there are three versions of what
happened next but the net effect of it
is is Edward lion a neighbor stole the
model machine one version is that he
disguised himself as a woman the second
version is that he broke in and the
third version is that he hired an
industrial spy I think the second
version is in he he and his people broke
in to the Whitney's workshop they took
the gin it was simple and
straightforward most plantations had
mechanics and blacksmiths there and
Edward lion went into the business of
producing cotton gins now Whitney got a
patent but the patent laws were weak
they were very weak and moreover he was
suing the aristocracy of the South the
plantation owners who were suddenly just
making money hand over fist I mean it
was like the software boom in the 1990s
with the dot-com companies and even more
importantly they were not really
interested in paying a substantial
royalty to Eli Whitney Whitney lost
sixty lawsuits in Georgia alone Whitney
quite literally went bankrupt trying to
protect his inventions
the loose laws of 1793 provided no
protections at all it was only in 1836
11 years after Whitney had died that the
United States created the modern patent
system with modern laws it was in that
era that Congress gave foreigners are
right to hold a patent the cost to a US
citizen was thirty dollars for foreigner
it was three hundred dollars for the
British int for a citizen of the British
Empire Congress made a special price
five hundred dollars Oh words you know
obviously had not held but before that
entering that 50-year period the United
States as I said had been a great pirate
nation the and I tell the story of the
first famous businessman in America it
is Frances law of Boston Frances law was
great Harvard graduate braman a great
merchant shipper in New England did
extensive business throughout Europe and
he set out in the early 1800s to steal
England's greatest industrial secret the
secret of the power loom and its really
the stuff of movies what he did no
mission impossible was better planned
than what he did Lowell pretended that
he had become ill and sick and that what
he needed was a European curative tour
so he took his wife he took his family's
unlike going to Lourdes or Germany or
baden-baden he got misdirected and round
up in Lancaster England he heard a large
coach palatial room paid courtesy calls
on all of the manufacturers of textiles
and they all showed him their machine it
was just unthinkable that this man
would steal anything he walked in with
no notes he had nothing they didn't
realize he had a photographic memory
every night he went back and took the
plans how he got his plans out of
England is one of the great mysteries
because at that period the British
double searched everyone in all their
bags because they were protecting the
secret of the fire limb you wound up
with he got logged got back to England I
mean back to the United States he built
a model the model was an improvement on
the British because he had access to all
of the manufacturers and he could
synthesize it and build a better company
he and his brother-in-law then built the
Boston counted Boston company is the
first corporation in America he invented
the first corporation in America he
built his system and he also built an
integrated milk you would bring cotton
or wool in one end and you would have
textiles coming out the other end his
first plant was able to produce a third
of a mile of textiles a day that is as
revolutionary as us colonizing the moon
it happened at just about the time of
the war of 1812 Frances law became the
lee iacocca the hero business man of his
of his time and then out of the
mechanics that it required to build the
loom you wound up with building machine
tools machines that could make machines
and then you became to precision
instruments it is not for nothing that
the Walton watch and all of the first
machine tools were centered around the
textile industry that coupled with the
invention of cotton made textiles our
first grade industry in this country I
also spend time in the middle period
talking about Thomas Edison
soon again is interesting from many
reasons Henry Ford called him the
greatest businessman I mean the greatest
inventor in the worst businessman in
American history he had this productive
mind he was able to organize people into
doing research he was brilliant at that
and when it came to business he was
totally incompetent he invented some
some lessons for inventors the first one
is he said never work on something that
is not going to pay commercially that
was his motto and that was because his
first invention Thomas Edison's first
invention was a mechanical device that
could quickly count votes in state
legislatures in the Congress total
failure it found it turns out that the
last thing that the politicians wanted
was a quick vote count they've got a
delayed vote count so they could Lobby
and do that Thomas Edison Thomas Edison
was the first movie part because our
copyright laws did not protect foreign
films he blatantly stole films out of
France and showed them in the United
States the French movie makers just
loathe Thomas Edison and it was
interesting to to read some of what he
did I also tell the story of Edison and
the telegraph system Ellison had over
200 patents on Telegraph's he was a
genius at telegraphy he invented a
machine that could send four messages
simultaneously over the same wire and he
decided that was not fast enough so he
invented the typewriter and the
typewriter was a device where he could
take clerks and type in messages large
number of messages that were going a
long strand and then they'd play that
strand over very fast over the wire just
and it would sound like a bee with the
stuff going over over the site to catch
it Thomas Edison invented a printer
there's something about this this I'm
talking to
in around 1871 he invented a printer
that could take a message and print at
3,000 words a minute I mean think you
know my printers does well to do 300 in
the principle that he used was the ball
many of you may remember the IBM
Selectric with the ball they got that
from Thomas Edison but what is gets even
more interesting with that he was always
hustling money for some other invention
he was always broke he was a he almost
in New Jersey he had the sheriff on his
payroll so the sheriff could never quite
find him to serve a summons and so he
squandered that great invention in a
fight with Jay ghoul the great white
shark of Wall Street in a lawsuit that
lasted for 30 years and finally Addison
one but he had so offended the judge and
the trustee the judge gave him a
one-dollar judgment on the whole thing
I've got to tell you when I was writing
this I had a tough time to stop doing
these odd stories of Thomas Edison he's
really fascinating and the biographies
of Edison there's several out there
they're really worth their reading I'll
stop with the the final story here that
I telling the book Edison invented an
improved Portland cement he had this
Eureka idea that homes in America should
be built of concrete and so he decided
to build suburbs vast suburbs of
affordable housing out of concrete the
kitchen would be concrete the shelves
would be concrete the showers and the
bass would be a concrete and of course
it didn't go but the one great monument
to Edison's concrete company that's left
the Yankee Stadium Thomas Edison built
Yankee Stadium of course
out of concrete it's still last the
second section of the book tells the
story of the technological rise of
Germany it tells how in world war one
German scientists save Germany saved the
Army the British cut off the nitrates
German scientists created nitrates for
explosives a German scientists were
producing things literally out of thin
air in the book also tells the madness
of Adolf Hitler those scientists who
saved Germany were forced out of Germany
in the first year one of the great basis
for science in this country was that
mass movement of something like 3,000
scientists 80-plus Nobel laureate
winners to the United States and it
happened very quickly I described
Japan's rise and how they systematically
have gone about taking technology also
described something that they don't
think most people realize Japan when the
war ended kept their economy on a
wartime footing when MacArthur went in
to Japan he brought with him a group of
new dealer a specialist their mindset
was it was the great families the mitsu
ease and the others that owned the
Koretz ooh that were controlling the
economy they did not realize that the
Japanese government had taken control of
those industries from the legitimate
owners of it in the late 1930s that it
was Japanese bureaucrats who were
running the economy and those companies
so what happened as the United States
divested the owners of their control and
we gave the control to the very people
who had been running the economy you end
up with three the post-war Japanese
Prime Minister's
that were elected up until the mid-1970s
were the people who had run the war
materiel command inside Japan total
control bringing technology in it would
have been as the Dwight Eisenhower had
put Albert Speer in his team in charge
of rebuilding Germany and the one thing
that you come away from the conclusion
that I come away from the conclusion is
how very competent the Japanese were how
very focused they are and how very
determined they have been to build a
world-class the leading technological
power in the world and then I tell the
stories of David Sarnoff and his fight
with Zenith radio how Zenith broke up
the patent pool from RCA and Sarnoff
literally wound up going to Japan and
giving all of the patents to the
Japanese to take down Zenith a move of
historic of historic petulance final
chapter in that segment tells the story
of China from 1926 and from 1979 to the
present and what they're doing I also
put in the hell you cannot understand
modern China unless you understand the
Treaty of Versailles and what went on at
the treaty of versailles and the
promises that we had made to the
japanese and did not keep the final
section talks about modern situation
modern circumstance in one chapter i
tell the story of how handful of
American CEOs led by the CEO of Pfizer
and IBM designed the brand new global
patent system convinced the US
government in the early 80s to do it
then went and convinced the European
business community and then the Japanese
community and quite literally change the
global
action that something called trips
trade-related intellectual property
system it is that the rest of the world
would adopt the American Standard and we
cut a deal that was organized we agreed
Europe's agreed Japan agreed that if
other countries would take an
american-style minimal set of
protections we would end all quotas on
the import of apparel and textiles into
the United States they can have apparel
and textiles that give us protection we
agreed to a 10-year facing that has cost
us a million jobs to this point the
United States in Europe in Japan are
keeping their part of that bargain what
we're finding is that other countries
notably China are not keeping that part
of the bargain and they are not
providing these protections the result
is piracy and counterfeiting over the
past ten years have become the great
crime of our time it cost our economy
250 billion a year we wind up with
twenty-five percent of the drugs coming
in from Mexico are fake drugs
twenty-five to fifty percent of the
drugs that come in over the internet
from Canada either a really trend
shipped from China India Russia and our
fake goods the Canadian goods and the
pharmacies are among the best in the
world just like theirs but it is those
that are shipped in we find that in
Africa calf the medicines are fake
they're of the World Health
Organization's list of vital medicines
about of 300 plus most are generic and
yet even though they're generic anyone
can make them they wind up
counterfeiters or faking them we wind up
with a million people a year dying of
malaria and of that most of that is
because the medicines they yet or fake
it is truly murder it is genocide that's
underway no one is immune inside this
country the Air Force recent
found a bogus cable on Air Force two and
break it half the strength we found in
42 airlines bogus cable was put in there
have been beta fake baby formula toys
with inflammable fabric children's
furniture of a dangerous lead paint all
certified as meeting standards the rule
of thumb is anything that can be faked
can be faked I conclude the book with
three basic recommendations the first
recommendation is there's three things
that we can do that I think unleash a
burst of creativity in this country
first is we crack down on there really
63 countries that are serving as
sanctuary for pirates and counterfeiters
those countries have a treaty obligation
with the United States to stop that they
have a treaty obligation with the United
States to provide minimal rights they're
not what I say we do and should do is
exercise our rights at the World Trade
Organization and bring suit against
those countries and collect the damages
and provide incentives the second thing
is in 1999 the Congress passed something
called the 18-month rule it's an obscure
provision it was in a much larger bill
I'll bet you money that no more than 20
members of Congress have even heard of
the 18-month room 18 months rule
requires the Patent Office to release to
the public all information within a
patent application at 18 months even if
no patent has been given it takes on
average 27 months now to get a patent
through and so the more complex patterns
it takes as long as six years 72 months
in that period between 18 months and the
27 months or the 72 months all of
inventors most vital secrets are owned
the internet for any pirate any
counterfeit or anywhere in the world
it's as though uh thoughtfully we
legalized industrial espionage we must
stop that we must change that law the
way I view it is we should go back to
the basic principles
this for over 200 years the federal
government has an absolute obligation to
defend the secrecy the creative persons
invention until they make a decision
whether or not that they're going to
give legal protection we want our
authors we want our inventors to be
protected the third thing is that
pendency rate we have a backlog now a
500,000 patents that in the warehouse
waiting we will have 400,000 patents
applications come in this year we're
able to process a little over 360
370,000 patent obligation we have 4,000
patent examiner's they're the best in
the world they're the absolute best in
the world creative bunch of people but
relative test it's a very small amount
of money that we spend about a billion
50 billion sexual spent about a billion
five on that and most of that is paid
for by fees we should take out of the
general revenues enough money to hire
enough patent examiner's and there are
plenty of good people out there with
outsourcing today they can fill these
jobs we should hire enough patent
examiner's if it's 2000 3000 4000 it
doesn't matter so that within three
years we've not only worked off the
backlog but they were getting patents
out in a shorter period such as six
months we're in a race with Asia and
we're in a race with Europe
technologically our people are creative
they do wonderful things it's it's truly
magic what our people are able to do but
we need those innovations now not two
and a half three years or six years this
small investment will produce the
greatest explosion of innovation that
one can imagine well let me stop there
I've gone longer than I wanted but I
didn't tell you nearly all the stories
that I that I have so let me take some
questions
we do have time for a few questions just
about 10 minutes if you could just use
the microphone um thanks I I got
interested in patent law because my room
college roommate was a translator in
French and patent law for wiper which by
the way is one of most beautiful
agencies UN agencies in in Geneva the
world intellectual property organization
I come from an academic background and
I'm then I'm also journalist I write a
lot about foreign students and I'm
concerned about that aspect of it the
the big battle for a long time in the
university's was battle between academic
freedom and patents with American
corporations well American sponsored
research by corporations has won that
battle but now the big battle is the i
call it the great wishing sound of our
intellectual property going abroad as
more and more foreign students dominate
our primary research in science and math
at over eighty percent of the scholars
at NIH out here are foreign and nobody's
checking what's leaving those campuses
but there is an intellectual academic
freedom supposedly how do how do you how
do you balance academic freedom with
with intellectual property especially
research is paid by public money I take
some of that own in this book
incidentally you called it a swishing
sound a friend of mine called it us
great sucking sound of something plating
basically I think that what we've got to
say in this country that we're going to
do is we've got to put a great deal more
money into our science and our research
and our training the second thing that
we've got to do is we've got to go back
to some of the principles that we
followed in the 50s and 60s we've got to
help students finance their way through
college
one reason large numbers of people don't
take that route is they don't want to
end their career with a come out with a
PhD and wind up with a quarter of a
million dollar debt or a large debt I
went I I literally went through seven
years of college and didn't pay a dime
worth the tuition because the state of
Oklahoma and the state of Texas paid
part and I think i paid back more than
enough taxes to make up that difference
if we said for example fifty thousand
dollars a year good education each
billion would take care of something
like twenty thousand students put five
billion put 10 billion so we need to
take care of that out as for the foreign
students in many cases the academic
institutions are literally financing
much of their operations because they're
getting the foreign talent and the
foreign students it would seem to me to
our advantage as the country to say that
we really do welcome the very best and
brightest students from around the world
we want them here we want them for the
contributions that they can make and I
think we should go one step further is I
think we should be willing to help pay
for their education if they'll make a
golden covenant with us is that they'll
stay here for a certain number of years
and we ease the they're acquiring
citizenship brains brains talent smarts
that's the primary resource of the 21st
century no matter how much we get we
can't get enough of it yes if you have
any thoughts on a current intellectual
property issue it has to do with Google
print and copyright & fair use google
has recently announced that it's going
to digitize 15 million books from five
major research libraries and for at
least three of those they're going to
digitize everything in the library
including the copyright
bucks right and make them freely keyword
searchable to anybody on the internet
now they've said that for the books
published after 1923 they're only going
to display snippets and they think or
they're claiming that that will be fair
use but they will be broadcasting for
free every snippet of the entire book
and in a way that brings money into
Google's coffers do you think that's a
fair reading of fair use I deal with
that in the last chapter of this book
rather extensively me to where I come
down on this issue the original
copyright law was for 14 years and if
you lived you could get an extension for
another 14 years if you lived as an
important consideration over time that
has been extended and extended and
extended I think we extended the
copyright terms 11 times since the late
1960s and each time the politics of that
is is you have tiny handful of
copyrighted materials that will have a
commercial life beyond two or three
years this book will have a commercial
life of maybe two years most books have
a commercial life of about that 95 98
percent of books and other things have a
very very short commercial life but
happy birthday for you which is patented
by Time Warner and produces them a
million dollars a year revenue will
probably be sung after the year twenty
to twenty eighteen when the pen the the
works of the Gershwins will probably be
extended and there's a whole number of
books that will be extended it's about
two percent of the copyrighted works now
those owners have every incentive in the
world to push the copyrights further at
the same time here we are with its vast
body of materials movies books articles
that are still under copyright in many
cases we don't know who owns the
copyright but if you're using it if your
google or somebody using it you always
run a substantial risk of it coming out
what I suggest is that we make a great
copyright deal and this is what I
propose and this is based on some ideas
that Lawrence Lessig is advocated and I
would put a little different twist on it
basically I think we should say we'll do
a great copyright deal will go back to
the same copyright law that the founding
fathers have 14 years but then say if
you want to extend your copyright you it
would be treated like a trademark and
you can extend it and you pay a nominal
fee to extend it but if you do not
extend your copyright then it
automatically goes in to the public
domain now for the first two years I
want my book copyrighted because I need
the royalties to pay my mortgage while
I'm writing the next book but after that
period of time I'd really like the
public to have and know what's in the
book in life the other six books I've
written I'd like them to have it in I'd
be totally willing to have it put into
the public domain and I like the idea I
like the idea of it happening
automatically now view it another way if
nike can own the swish on a trademark
forever why shouldn't disney-owned
Mickey Mouse forever now it's not a
perfect deal it doesn't take you to the
purest stance but what it will do is it
will open up what I'm suggesting will
open up a treasure-house of materials
and just think once there the the 1920s
all the materials in the books the Great
Depression the World War 2 the Golden
Age of music first she all those works
are locked up now now there's a
political chance of an ice cube in Hades
for copyright terms to be like that yeah
I do and I tell you yeah I do it sitting
thing about
the copyright industry you know they won
the supreme court case 722 that was
brought up on the challenging the sonny
bono act but now the conference out at
seventy years plus the author's live for
95 years on a commercial basis think
it's pretty hard to justify now i think
politically they can raise enough money
and probably push it through in another
twelve years that's just my take on it
but on the other hand here you've got a
group it would be in their interest to
make this deal now and it would be in
the interest of those of us who believe
in public domain to make this deal if we
can get ninety-five percent of the
materials into the public domain that's
pretty darn good and it's disorder the
art of politics thank you hi i've got to
if i could do them quickly sure first
there's no incentive for good pattin's
i'm a patent researcher i do not in
prior art for a living and there are
actually disincentives for good patents
because examiner's while they're
wonderful have a quota short amount of
time that we get them through there
needs to be better incentives for good
patterns he says a lot of junk out there
and they're not worth much and the
second you do very nice research i'm
wondering i'd like to ask you about how
you do it but I wondered lowly very
slowly I wonder if you know similar to
your your statistic about not not much
as earned after the first two years of a
book I'm depending on paperback
hardcover very few patent litigation
cases ever get that are awarded ever do
more than pay the attorneys involved
very very view like the whole less
single digit or much less and there are
very few successful cases any comments
on eros I deal with that it I got
interested in this whole claim that
there's a litigation crisis and patents
and the the numbers to me do not suggest
that they are what we wind up with is
there will be somewhere in the
neighborhood of 2400 to 25 suits
actually go to trial this year patent
suits now that'll actually go that's
three tenths of one percent of the
patents take my high numbers because it
works out interestingly even with the
high numbers of the suits that go the
patent owner wins about sixty percent of
the cases when you take it to the
appellant that's right you take it to
the appellate court the patent is upheld
75 to 80 percent since you've created
the 1982a now what that tells me is this
you basically have a very strong system
to get a patent to hold it it's got to
go through an examiner and I fully agree
with you we need more examiner's and
they need more time and to take it
through but they're taking it through
experts then it goes through trial by
fire in a federal court case and then
you have an appellate court that is
composed of judges who were very
knowledgeable about patents and so what
it really says here is that we have I
think a very strong patent system not a
perfect system but a system where most
of the patents that go through or earned
now there are certain things that maybe
we don't want to have patented maybe we
don't not want a peanut and butter jelly
sandwich patented that's a political
decision but by and large we've got a
great great patent system thank you for
the question
shifting gears that wee bit would you
care to comment on what impact you feel
running as a vice presidential candidate
head on your literary interests and
writing skills well it certainly made me
wanted to pursue it more versus politics
running for vp was a is was a wonderful
experience it was an accident we
couldn't talk a real politician in to
running met interesting people across
the country and one of the things i
learned from all of the political
speeches is people really do like good
stories they like good stories and so i
have shifted my writing style is
basically what I've tried to do with
this book is you're going to learn a lot
about patents and you're going to learn
a lot about copyrights but I try to do
it in such a way that I slip up on you
that when you finish you know a lot but
you're talking about the stories I've
tried to make it a good read for you
well listen I thank you very much for
coming out tonight and it's a great
pleasure to be back here I hope I can
come four more times in the future and
thank you very much okay thanks to catch
oh thanks for being here tonight the
books are available in the front of
store come back have Pat Choate co-wrote
Savior job save our country with ross
perot his latest book hot property is
published by alfred a knopf visit their
website at a a Knopf calm